JEREMY: Welcome to YouTube
Developers Live.
I'm here with VidIQ.
My name's Jeremy.
And we have Rob and Todd.
ROB: Thanks for having us.
JEREMY: Great.
Well let's jump right into it.
Tell us a little bit about the
history of your company.
ROB: Great.
So we started about
a year ago.
But really this idea originated
and this passion
six, seven years ago when Todd
and I were working on Viddler,
our first startup, which was
providing a white-label video
hosting solution
to businesses.
And what we found after working
with thousands of
companies was--
the common question was,
why aren't you
providing a YouTube solution?
Why isn't there a focus on
YouTube with your white-label
video product.
And with that, we made the
decision let's go all in on
YouTube and help these
companies, these businesses
maximize their presence on
YouTube to get more views,
more subscribers, waste less
time on managing all that and
providing an efficient product
for them, so they could focus
on their production.
JEREMY: Sounds like the idea
kind of came from some
experience with your past
startup, and you just saw the
trend, and you decided
to ride it.
ROB: That's correct.
And we moved from the East coast
to San Francisco here,
went through IO Ventures and we
were successful in closing
a seed on Mark Cuban, Scott
Banister, and a number of
other prolific investors
here in the Bay Area.
And it's been a fun
ride so far.
JEREMY: Awesome.
So tell me a little bit
more about what's
the main goal then?
ROB: So we say we work
with brands.
Brands might be content
creators.
It might be networks, the
MCNs, brands in general.
JEREMY: MCNs are multi-network
channels, for anybody that
doesn't know.
ROB: They're growing, right?
You go to L.A, and it's all
that anyone talks about.
And so we really provide a
product that helps them focus
on their audience
development--
more views, more subscribers
and again more time being
focused on their content
rather than the land of
YouTube and Facebook and Twitter
and maximizing your
audience that we provide a
suite of tools that helps
streamline all of that.
JEREMY: Great.
So less time worrying about
finding the audience and more
about making great content.
ROB: Correct.
JEREMY: So let's jump
right into it.
I know our audience loves
to see demos, so let's
go right into that.
ROB: So I don't know if we can
pull up my screen here in this
framework Chromebook,
by the way.
JEREMY: OK.
Go ahead.
ROB: Are we live?
JEREMY: Yeah.
ROB: So what we're seeing
here is Revision3
has a dashboard now.
We did get permission from Jim
Louderback in Revision3.
Thanks Jim.
We appreciate that.
And we're here showing stats
that we're grabbing from--
I know you can't see this
--stats from their YouTube
channels in the heads-up
fashion.
So this is not only the
YouTube data, the
subscriptions, the comments
and whatnot.
But we're also grabbing
Facebook data.
How many shares and likes
and comments are
occurring on Facebook.
How many tweets around these
YouTube URLs are occurring.
And so we will give you relative
data on how those
things are all performing in
relation to each other.
We do that holistically, from
a heads-up dashboard.
So you can compare here, for the
audience that's watching,
how may be my YouTube watch
times comparing against the
tweets on the individual
video.
JEREMY: That's great.
So like you're using
our analytics API.
And one of our main use cases to
use that is to combine with
other data and make
sense out of it.
So you guys are bringing in all
of the social channels and
bringing that together.
ROB: And I think that this
wouldn't be possible without
the V3 API.
TODD: Yeah.
We found that v3 API, you get
a lot faster for real time.
So this is actually a proxy call
to YouTube to grab this
graph in real time and plot it
against the data we have
internally about tweets and
Facebook data, shares,
comments, and likes.
JEREMY: Great.
Sorry.
Didn't mean to interrupt.
ROB: No.
Love it.
What we're viewing here
is kind of how we
view individual videos.
Are we just looking at a
holistic view on the channel?
Now we're looking at
individual videos.
And we're grabbing, again, more
than just the YouTube
data-- that's the tweets,
it's the Facebook likes.
And one of the things that's
helping discoverability is we
built this tag recommender
that you can run on your
individual videos.
So if you wanted--
I have 10 different tags.
I'm looking for 15
more, or 10 more.
Todd's been doing some fantastic
data work on trying
to find a relational,
high-volume, relatively low
competitive tags or search
terms that we
could optimize against.
So again, with this notion that
most of your videos are
discovered in related
videos in search.
Where is the YouTube SEO company
that's helping these
brands maximize their
presence on YouTube.
And that's kind of a
big void that we're
helping fill right now.
JEREMY: Great.
TODD: And so to make it easy,
you can just select from this
list and add really quickly
whatever it recommends.
ROB: So we also, just for basic
asset management, we
have an ability to upload from
the URL or from the browser.
So if you have something in
Dropbox, you can quickly share
a Dropbox link, send it
to a YouTube channel.
That way you're not downloading
it from Dropbox
and re-sending it to YouTube.
You can just send it directly
to YouTube.
JEREMY: You kind of just take
care of that on the back end.
ROB: On the back end.
Yeah.
JEREMY: Great.
ROB: Again, another thing
using the API--
what I'm walking into here is
our mass description editor.
This is something that
you can create.
You guys have fantastic mass
editing tools on the
description side.
But if you want to treat it
like a campaign and get
click-through rates and views
and number of clicks on those,
and quickly turned it on and
off, we help manage that,
which isn't an easy task.
But we help do that.
So if you wanted to quickly
share a link that goes out
against all of your channels--
and we really encourage
people to promote
their latest videos.
Like, send traffic to YouTube.
Don't send them away from
YouTube on their description,
because that's only going
to hurt your watch time.
As we both know, watch time is
absolutely critical right now
with YouTube.
JEREMY: Yeah, we as we like to
view that as one of our main
[INAUDIBLE].
ROB: And so you can
drive traffic with
the click of a button.
JEREMY: And so you guys would
run across all videos, pull
descriptions and add the links
and all of them, so they can
just do it in one [INAUDIBLE]
and push it
out to all of them.
ROB: Yes.
JEREMY: Great.
ROB: Yeah.
That wasn't--
how easy was that one?
TODD: Little tricky.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TODD: It's cool to see
it run though.
You've got a bunch of servers,
so it doesn't parallel.
It's called a "watch it run."
ROB: One of the key things that
we discus a lot of around
the YouTube API is managing our
quota, and how do we queue
the calls that we have, whether
they be urgent calls,
or low priority calls?
How do we create a system that
works well on YouTube.
And that's not an easy task.
But it's something I think you
have to think about, for all
the developers out there,
when you're
building on top of YouTube.
It's something that, when you
start dealing with thousands
of channels like we are, you
run into those issues.
JEREMY: Yeah, you might need
to optimize to make sure
you're not killing your
quota right away.
And we actually have a blog
post article on that.
So any of you that are
interested, check that out.
But definitely, that's a great
thing to point out, to think
about that when you
start designing.
ROB: And you guys have been
fantastic in directing us to
help solve those problems.
We're very appreciative.
We have a fan page app
that takes your
YouTube videos to Facebook.
It's more Facebook
in that context.
So we'll just move forward
to influencers.
We will expose the top
influencers on your channel.
People that are engaging with
your videos, whether that be
on YouTube or on Twitter.
And we encourage content
creators to reach out to these
types of influencers, whether it
be a cross-promotional type
of deal where you're getting
them to host you on their
show, or bring you
on their show.
There's a lot of reasons why
you might want to further
engage with these, whether
it's just sending them a
subscribe or a simple note,
saying thanks for watching us.
But the data around
this is actually--
and the algorithm that we came
to come up with this leader
board of top influencers is
actually quite interesting.
I don't know if you want to--
TODD: Yeah sure.
We're using subscriber data
and how long they're on
YouTube, and then just various
metrics about the profile that
we download, and to score any
one's that commented or
tweeted about your channel.
So we can compile the ones we
think are the most interesting
for you to contact.
JEREMY: Great.
ROB: I'm stepping into
the Twitter portion.
What we'll do is go and look
at all of the YouTube URLs
that are being shared on Twitter
and, in a list format,
share with you the
tweets coming in.
We'll give you the Klout Score
about the Twitter user.
We'll give you the YouTube URL
and the YouTube title that's
being exposed on Twitter.
So what we built is
this capacity to
sort by Klout Scores.
So you can say hey, if Tony
Robbins tweets out one of my
YouTube URLs, that you should
probably know about that.
And if you're just using
HootSuite or one of these
other Twitter solutions, you
might not be looking for all
of thousands of your
YouTube URLs.
You might just be looking for
@Revision3 or @YouTube.
You're not looking for the
specific YouTube URL.
And Revision3--
I'm sorting by Klout, and
Revision3 tweets from YouTube
as some of their most
influential people that are
tweeting about them.
TODD: We found, I think it was
like 90% of [INAUDIBLE] rough
statistically, 90% of tweets
about your videos don't
mention your brand.
It's just a YouTube link that
has a video URL in it.
So this surfaces a ton
of conversations
that you're not seeing.
JEREMY: Oh great.
ROB: Now that's light on--
we're just grabbing the
YouTube URLs or from the
API on that side.
But in the same kind of notion,
we're bringing YouTube
comments forth.
So if you want to manage all
of your comments on a
real-time basis, in one heads-up
dashboard, we're
providing an interface
to go and do that.
We'll expose subscriber data.
If you want to narrow down all
the comments from that
individual user, you can
go ahead and do that.
And in the same way you can
sort by reputation.
Who are the top subscribers, who
has the most subscribers
that's commenting on
my YouTube videos.
And let me go and address
that audience.
Because they're much
more influential.
They're much more worth
talking to.
JEREMY: Yeah, that
makes sense.
That totally makes sense.
ROB: Again, this whole notion
of saving time.
Like, don't waste time managing
hundreds of thousands
of comments when you can narrow
that down to just 50 of
the most relevant.
Especially for the bigger
creators on YouTube,
this is a big deal.
TODD: It's a proven way
to get views too.
Like we noticed videos that have
at least one comment from
you in them from the channel
owner have, I think it's like
three times, four times,
more views.
So engaging that audience,
especially to the people that
are influential, is going to be
better than buying views or
any of these crazy strategies
people are using
to grow their audience.
JEREMY: That's an interesting
insight.
This is great.
ROB: And you can reply
from any of your
off-channels, right.
So if you have five different
YouTube accounts, and you want
to reply from maybe your
personal one and not your
corporate one, you can do so
very cleanly in this UI, as
you can see.
JEREMY: Great.
ROB: And it's real time.
So we just added that, I think,
two or three weeks ago.
So this was actually a pretty
big API challenge, just
getting this interface to act
real-time when someone's
logged in actively
on the dashboard.
TODD: As you load the comments
page, it's going across all
your videos and looking
for new comments.
You can see here, it's like a
bubble that's telling you
there's one more there that it
found across all your videos.
JEREMY: Great.
ROB: It's like in Twitter
search, it says like, hey,
five more tweets.
Hit this to refresh.
Kind of that same UI.
And it's just a time saver.
If you're getting notified via
email via your tweets or your
comments, and then
you're going back
and forth, it's just--
meanwhile you can just
keep this up.
Hey, I got five more comments
I gotta manage.
I got 100 more comments
Bam, click it.
I'm in there.
Do I gotta respond?
Do I gotta delete any of them?
Moderate and move on.
JEREMY: That's great.
That kind of gives them
a place to centralize
everything.
ROB: Yeah.
JEREMY: So just a
quick question.
So what are you guys using on
the back end, what language?
TODD: That's Ruby on Rails.
JEREMY: Ruby on Rails.
TODD: We've got some JavaScript
that in Python, too.
But primarily the back
end is Ruby.
JEREMY: OK great.
And now you guys, I know for
sure you're using the
analytics API again,
the new one.
And you guys helped
us out a lot.
You were early trusted testers
for that, which was great.
The data API obviously, because
you guys are doing
some of the comment stuff and
some of the uploads and some
of the management of YouTube.
And the player API, I'm
guessing as well?
TODD: I think that for just the
Facebook, which I don't
know if you've showed
that yet.
We're just using a chromeless
API for that.
JEREMY: Great.
And so when you were starting
implementing them, did you run
into-- so it sounds like
obviously you guys used so
much data, and you have quite
a few clients, so you were
hitting your quota limit.
So you had to plan
out for that.
Did you guys run into
any other things
that surprised you?
ROB: So we left private
beta two, three
months ago, end of February.
And we offer now a free product
that anyone can use,
just get a little bit
of a taste of what
they can do with VidIQ.
And we had to prepare for
that influx of demand.
And Todd, you can hint on the
level of sophistication.
TODD: We had to get some--
you guys hooked us up
with more quota.
That was super helpful.
That was actually a huge
challenge in this was building
something that could ingest
YouTube data this fast and
accurately.
We were surprised by the
complexity of the quota system
and how it's kind of
unpredictable.
Some calls cost more
than others.
And it seems like certain
times of day--
it seems like, it's kind
of like a black
box, the quota system.
And we got good at it just
by trial and error.
And so now we can prioritize
a certain-- like if a user
on-boards, as soon as they
[INAUDIBLE] we download all
this data about them
really quickly.
We prioritize that over
our background
jobs and other things.
So yeah, I mean, we
figured it out.
I think it would've been less
surprising if we could predict
we can do this many
calls per day.
It got a little better in v3.
You guys have an easier-to-use
quota system.
But even then, there's
like some things
that cost 4x and 3x.
And it's kind of still
not totally clear.
Like, how many customers can I
take on and have live today.
It's a hard question
to answer.
I was kind of all
over the place.
JEREMY: Yeah.
No, that makes sense.
We do provide some
information.
I think for you guys, you're
probably looking more at like
almost a data warehouse, where
you want all the information
all the time, like
on a daily basis.
And I've talked to you guys
about this, but we're building
a schedule reports feature, so
that you can schedule reports
and then pick them up on a daily
basis which wont' have
quite the quota impact on you.
So that, the analytics API,
which is more like a dashboard
and bring information in, you
can use it for more real-time
information, where the
scheduled report--
you can pull all that data
information in and not worry
about the impact on your
quota as much.
TODD: That could
be interesting.
ROB: We talk with a lot of
creators and brands.
And they want to know the
data immediately.
They upload that video, they
want to see the views, they
want to see the comments,
they want--
like, especially with
that one, it's like
one video at a time.
Like, I want to live
and breathe
that while it's occurring.
And if the data is two days old
or a day old, or it's a
CSV export at night, it can be
challenging to serve that user
in a meaningful way.
Now there's a lot of data
out there that we
can go out and get.
But the more the better.
JEREMY: Yeah, that's what we
hear-- the more the better.
ROB: Push.
Push data too.
TODD: That's the
big one for us.
There's a question later, but
getting push notifications.
You have pubsubhubbub
on certain fees,
but not all of them.
And something that would be
awesome is, you're just
getting that across all videos
or even like a Twitter
streaming API kind of a thing,
where we can get just updates
and listen to a socket and find
out this many comments in
or five more views came in.
It would be awesome to
be able to show that,
real-time, to users.
I remember a prior show,
Jeff mentioned that.
He's like, yeah, push
notifications.
JEREMY: I mean, for Push we're
working on some things we
can't quite talk about yet.
But we are doing that.
And we are aware that people
do want like this fire hose
feed, or whatever you
want to call it.
So we are aware of that.
Yeah, the Push notifications
we hear a bit.
Great.
Is there anything else
you wanted to--
ROB: We have one last thing
where it's a mess.
SEO optimizer.
So we'll go and analyze
all of your videos.
And again this is where looking
at a lot of data helps
and understand what might be the
most impactful tags to add
on a specific channel.
And so we'll weight, like,
by score [INAUDIBLE].
And the one we're looking
at here is Wine Library.
Wines from Egypt should
be tagged with Egypt.
And we're just analyzing the
incoming search, analyzing the
tags, analyzing the titles,
seeing where there might be
room for optimization across
all their videos.
So I think this is one of our
more valuable features.
This is why we get a
lot of customers.
Because we're one of the few
guys really focused on search
and related videos.
And this definitely, we've
found, provided organic life.
JEREMY: Well, I really
appreciate you guys coming in.
Anything you'd like to add?
I mean it sounds like you'd like
to add for new developers
that are thinking of using
any of these APIs?
It sounds like definitely plan
with quota in mind, to
optimize around that.
Anything else?
TODD: So when we first built
this, we built it in v2, the
v2 API, just because
v3 didn't exist.
And if I was doing it today,
I would do it in v3.
I would use the analytics
API and v3 data API.
And probably start thinking
about quota early.
It's hard to wrap your
head around.
JEREMY: Great.
Yeah, anybody out
there, use v3.
That's our new version.
We're definitely pushing that.
It's built on a whole
new stack.
So all the new features
are coming into that.
So we do have some
questions open.
And we have one for you guys.
Do you guys actually
have an API?
TODD: Yeah.
We do.
This whole app is like a--
it has a JavaScript API
that runs in the--
the entire JavaScript app
runs with an AJAX API.
So we have one.
It's not exposed in
documentation or anything.
I think if there was use-case,
or if someone wanted to talk
to us, we could easily get
them on board with API
instructions.
So it exists, but it's
just not documented.
ROB: We do have two clients.
So we're working with a few
clients right now on this
front as well.
If anyone's interested,
API@VidIQ.com is where we've
been directing people.
And what will we provide?
I think some of the stuff
is very SEO specific.
So I think some of the
SEO has been like--
how do I get this data into my
CMS has been the question that
we've gotten a lot.
JEREMY: So definitely check
with you guys on that.
ROB: Yeah, we're open.
JEREMY: Great.
Well, I think that
wraps it up.
We always like to plug
we are hiring at
YouTube, Developers here.
So if you're interested,
definitely let us know.
A big thanks to you guys for
coming today and for being
trusted testers and giving us
feedback on the new APIs.
And anything you'd
like to add.
ROB: Just thanks, by the way,
trusting us with the API and
the data that customers
are authing with us.
That's a big privilege that
we don't take lightly.
And I think a lot of
the app developers
out there don't either.
TODD: Thanks for building
the new APIs.
A huge step in modernizing
YouTube APIs in v3.
We're very happy about that.
So congratulations on
that milestone.
JEREMY: Yeah.
Thank you.
We definitely want everyone
to move to those.
So if you haven't checked them
out, definitely check out the
new versions.
And thanks for joining
us today.